le secteur financier doit s'adapter aux
différentes innovations technologiques
au changement climatique aussi que fait
l'Autorité des marchés financiers du
Québec pour y arriver avec nous ce soir
Louis Morisset qui est le PDG de l'AMF
bonsoir Monsieur Morisset bonsoir
Monsieur Fillon c'est très facile
aujourd'hui d'investir avec l'Internet
nous sommes très sollicités on reçoit
des textos on reçoit des courriels il y
a les crypto-monnaies il y a les réseaux
sociaux il y a l'intelligence
artificielle on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
de tchat GPT au cours des dernières
semaines est-ce que le secteur financier
complètement transformation complètement
bousculé par tout ça absolument une
transformation qui s'est amorcée il y a
quelques années mais qui s'est accéléré
notamment avec la pandémie donc cette
transformation numérique si on veut du
secteur financier de plus en plus de
services de produits sont offerts à la
population via Internet évidemment et
justement un des éléments à garder à
l'esprit c'est qu'il faut faire à faire
avec des entreprises qui sont inscrites
ici au Québec se trouve facile
aujourd'hui avec les fournisseurs de
services qu'on peut trouver partout à
travers le monde qui pas encadré il faut
absolument faire attention parce que
parce qu'il y a des risques de fraude
notamment et qui sont dans le fond de
trébucher sur des sur des pièges qui
sont qui sont évitables et les pièges
sont faciles autrefois c'était beaucoup
plus difficile dans un sens de de se
faire avoir ou en tout cas d'établir une
fraude aujourd'hui on nous envoie
quelque chose à cliquer puis on se fait
avoir sur le champ c'est quoi votre rôle
pour protéger le public face à ça mais
c'est un rôle de sensibilisation au
premier chef parce que c'est des
entreprises sont établies à l'étranger
on n'a pas de contrôle sur ces
entreprises là puis l'Internet tout le
monde y a accès alors on sensibilise on
Martel les mêmes messages faites
attention j'ai faite à faire avec des
entreprises inscrites ici au Québec ce
qui est trop beau c'est pour être vrai
et souvent une fraude donc on Martel
s'est message là puis on fait appel
aussi à l'industrie financière ici au
Québec de contribuer avec nous à
l'éducation financière des Québécois
Ultima et des Québécoises bien sûr et
ultimement aiguiser le reflète le
réflexe de vigilance parce que c'est une
tâche qui est colossale on en fait une
grande partie qu'on a besoin de l'aide
de l'industrie avez-vous les moyens de
surveiller
d'encadrer d'intervenir mais nos moyens
sont limités encore une fois lorsque
l'entreprise est basée à l'étranger on
peut pas rien faire ben il y a des
moyens encore une fois qui peuvent
parfois être déployés essayer de faire
des blocages par exemple pour des
résidents du Québec d'avoir accès via
internet à certains à certains sites
mais c'est très difficile donc c'est des
mises en garde que l'on fait on avertit
on ré avertit la population de faire
attention on a une liste assez longue
sur notre site internet d'entreprise
pour lesquelles on a la conviction
quelles ont été frauduleuses ou qu'elles
pourraient l'être donc c'est vraiment de
la sensibilisation
lorsque des entreprises ont notre
territoire évidemment on peut on peut
intervenir mais l'élanjeux est beaucoup
les entreprises basées à l'étranger les
arnaques donc ont changé les fraudes ont
changé oui depuis je pense à la faire
normaux par exemple il y a presque 20
ans oui puis entre avec l'engouement des
crypto des cryptos actifs depuis trois
ans on a vu un engouement pour la
population en général envers les cryptos
actifs et il y a des il y a des
plateformes qui permettent de transiger
qui donc des plateformes qui sont
inscrites qui sont réglementées au
Canada mais il y en a une panoplie qui
ne le sont pas puis encore une fois
votre message à la MF sur sur les
cryptos
monnaie officiellement vous dites quoi
aux gens aujourd'hui après l'année quand
même qu'on vient de connaître ou les
cryptos ont quand même chuté puis il y a
des scandales mais d'être excessivement
prudent d'être excessivement prudent
parce que c'est volatile c'est purement
spéculatif c'est souvent frauduleux
alors il faut à tout le moins faire
affaire avec une entreprise qui est
inscrite une plateforme inscrite puis
assurément justement pas cliquer sur les
liens qui apparaissent comme ça puis de
faire affaire avec des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas est-ce que vous travaillez
avec facebook est-ce que vous travaillez
TikTok est-ce que vous travaillez avec
les plateformes par où peuvent passer
aussi certaines fraudes on essaie ça se
fait au niveau international il y a des
il y a des échanges qui ont
peuvent parter maintenant ben écoutez ça
a été une décision difficile à prendre
parce que je suis pleinement engagé
investi dans la mission de l'autorité
depuis longtemps maintenant après deux
mandats de 5 ans je suis arrivé à la
conclusion que les objectifs que je
m'étais fixés au terme de mes mandats
sont substantiellement atteints
l'organisation est solide j'ai une
équipe de haute direction solide une
organisation qui s'est améliorée de
façon impressionnante au cours des 10
dernières années donc je suis confiant
de partir à ce stade ci et puis que non
dans le milieu d'affaires dans le milieu
financier peut-être j'ai aucune idée
encore ma réflexion s'est concentrée sur
la décision que j'ai prise celle de ne
pas solliciter un mandat va falloir que
j'amorce une décision une réflexion pour
la suite après commencer à y penser je
vous le conseille prochain PDG donc on
verra qui sera nommé au cours des
prochains mois merci Monsieur Morisset
merci Monsieur pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI
[Musique]